[Music]
what happens when we keep the leftover
food on the table for the entire night
when we see the container in the morning
we find that it is shared by some new
members yes along with the food we even
find fungus growing in the container so
what do we do in such cases needless to
say we throw it away
this is because if we consume the food
shared by fungus then we may encounter a
variety of health issues this happens
because the food has now turned into a
poison for us wait a second
how can the delicious food of the
previous night turned poisonous this
morning that too only with the mere
presence of fungi the fact that fungi
grow over it is enough to explain this
yes when microbes of any type take over
our food they release certain substances
in it and these substances are quite
toxic for us and hence we say that the
food has turned poisonous this gets us
to the concept of food poisoning in the
simplest words we can define food
poisoning as the ill effect on health
caused by consumption of contaminated
food and how does the food get
contaminated it gets contaminated due to
toxic secretions by certain bacteria
fungi parasites and any other type of
pathogen present in it consumption of
such contaminated food leads to various
types of severe infections in our
digestive system so is there something
we can do to avoid poisoning of our food
scientifically spoiled food is a result
of chemical reactions yes the harmful
microbes in our food give out certain
secretions that bring out chemical
changes in the food these chemical
changes render it unfit for consumption
so can we save our food from spoiling by
interrupting these chemical reactions of
course we can and the only way to do
this is by inhibiting the microbial
growth or simply killing these microbes
either ways we do not allow the toxic
secretions
enter our food but how can this be
achieved well there are several ways of
carrying out food preservation a few
methods have been carried out since ages
while some have been recently developed
let's have a glance at the chemical
methods of food preservation first we
always find a grandma adding lots of
salt and oil to the pickle she makes
every year and the pickle if you notice
tastes the same throughout the year have
you ever wondered how this happens well
this is an ancient method of food
preservation that we use adding
commodities like salt oil and even
vinegar arrest the growth of microbes in
the food even if microbes attack a food
they get killed among all salt is the
most commonly and widely used not only
pickles
but salt is also used for preservation
of meat and fishes yes
salting of meat and fish followed by
drying them in the Sun can't reserve
them for many months together do you
know any such commodity that we use
daily which acts as a preservative you
must have observed that jams and jellies
are added with wholesome amount of sugar
yes it is because sugar is also used as
a preservative apart from making the
jams and jellies sweet sugar also
inhibits microbial growth in it well
these were the commonly used commodities
which were employed to preserve food in
our homes or even on a small scale but
what about the food items manufactured
or processed on a large scale some food
items cannot be added with large amount
of oil or salt in such cases a few
chemicals come to our rescue yes now
apart from salting oiling or adding
sugar we have certain chemicals that can
be added to the food in order to
preserve it the most commonly used
chemicals include sodium benzoate and
sodium metabisulfite these chemicals
prevent the growth of microbes in our
food and what kinds of food items can be
saved by these chemicals we
add them to squashes fruit juices and
even certain fruit jams now these four
the methods where the food items were
added with some preservatives but what
about those consumables which cannot be
added with any such preservatives wait a
second
we can add preservatives to almost all
food items then which consumables are we
referring to well have you ever thought
of adding salt or oil to milk for
preservation
how will you add sugar or vinegar to
fruits and vegetables these consumables
cannot be preserved with any chemical
treatment for them
we need well-designed physical methods
for preservation to know these methods
you will have to watch our next video
[Music]